économie adrian bonjour aux questionnant
les taux d'intérêt qui pourrait doubler
éventuellement oui bon la banque du
canada n'a pas l'intention de les
doubler à moyen terme
pas à court terme non plus mais ça
pourrait survenir peut-être un petit peu
plus tôt que ce à quoi on s'attendait
récemment la banque du canada qui a
laissé tomber sa menace dos et les taux
d'intérêt n'est celle ocde
l'organisation de coopération et de
développement économiques qui rêvait ses
prévisions mondiales pour l'école la
croissance aujourd'hui et qui appelle la
banque du canada à faire quelque chose
avec son taux directeur disons qu'il ya
plusieurs facteurs en ce moment qu'il
inquiète notamment la possible hausse
des prix poussée de l'inflation qui sera
envisagée peut-être en 2014 parce qu'on
anticipe à ce moment là une accélération
de la croissance
il ya aussi le marché l'immobilier qui
restait très vigoureux justement parce
que les taux sont extrèmement bas
on dit du canada que c'est l'un des pays
dans le monde où les actifs immobiliers
sont les plus surévaluées alors ça
chicotte franchement l' ocde qui demande
à la banque du canada de hausser son
taux directeur de le doubler de le faire
passer à 2,25 pour cent d'ici la fin
en ce moment le taux directeur est à 1%
ça pourrait donc commencer à grimper
quelque part d'ici là l'an prochain 10 6
1 en hausse progressive donc pour
doubler les taudis jusqu'à 2,25 pour
cent d'ici la fin de 2013
et maintenant c'est au tour de bombarder
de remporter des contrats au salon de
dubaï
oui on disait hier que dans le cadre de
cesse de ce salon aéronautique
bombardier n'avait pas encore vendu
d'appareils cseries c'est maintenant le
cas c'est maintenant chose faite à un
transporteur de l'irak
iraqi airways qui a signé une lettre
d'intention pour acheter cinq de ses
avions de modèle cs300 donc le plus gros
appareil de la famille cseries
c'est une commande qui est estimé à 400
millions de dollars la valeur pourrait
quand même atteindre un milliard deux
cent soixante millions $ si toutes les
options sont exercées
ça c'est pour la commande pour les
cseries il ya deux autres contrats qui
sont conclues aujourd'hui des contrats
pour l'appareil biturbopropulseur q400
l'un avec un transporteur de la
thaïlande pour 63 millions de dollars et
un autre contrat similaire avec abu
dhabi aviation donc une récolte positive
pour mon parti en cette troisième
journée de ce salon de dubaï qui se
termine je vous le rappelle juste et
puis les marchés boursiers traiteur si
les marchés boursiers
des pertes assez important du côté de
l'europe en ce moment parce que l' ocde
dont je vous parlais à l'instant oui à
réviser ses prévisions de croissance
pour le canada mais aussi pour la
croissance mondiale et on les a révisé à
la baisse ce qui fait chuter donc les
principaux indices d'un quart à presque
1 point de pourcentage en ce moment par
contre du côté de l'amérique du nord
vous allez voir c'est un début de séance
très calme on a des variations de
quelques points à peine dollar canadien
se maintient on est à 95 cents
américains et 75 centièmes
ça se maintient aussi pour le prix du
brut tombés sous les 93 dollars
américains à new york
il retient de rire devant pouvoir voir